foreign
it is September 12 2023 we're here in
the active inference for the social
sciences course at the Active inference
Institute and having a discussion
section on semiotics and semantics here
with Lorena secancerla
we're going to be having a fun
discussion I hope if you're watching
live please feel free to write any
questions in the live chat if
you thought about joining you are sure
it's not too late otherwise we're gonna
pick up on some key points from the
lecture and on the topic and see where
we go so
Lorena
welcome back
and
however you want to begin let's go from
there
okay hello thank you Daniel
um
so let's try to recap a little bit where
we left off in during the lecture
um
just to remind us where we were like my
point what I was trying to articulate uh
was the idea of
what does it mean to talk about a formal
semantics in a way that is not really
loaded because
it's an interesting thought like to have
a semantic
semantics that is actually only formal
right in principle it would be
relative to meaningful
uh to meaning right in in the notion
that
active inference
is trying to cash it out
he
is it's more like an idea or a way of
modeling how
how we deal with meaningful situations
and she understand that in a more
interesting more embodied and more
concrete way I was suggesting that we
could use
biosemiotics as
uh
as a model and as a theory who
living creatures like language users to
navigate the realm of symbols
and give one example which came from
uh James Koch which is the European
forestry that comes with a practice
understanding this scientific
understanding of forests as a practice
that me that allows us to
to refer to meaningful
too meaningful things in the environment
in terms of what is valuable what's
interesting and what is not
and
what interestingly what is more
important also from what becomes
valuable it is what
is
cropped out from
eliminating for perspective so things
natural uh parts of nature becomes left
out or understood as something that is
not desirable and you just understand
what you don't want in your
articulating Principle as weeds or
something that you should
get rid of
in respect to what is more desirable in
terms of crowds and how you understand
nature in a more
commoditized way
and I find like this example from God
kind of very very
elucidating
uh in in the book he creates this in the
book he's talking about States how we
articulate life around one specific
notion of stage but in this specific
example he has the idea of one official
Observer and this official Observer
establishes a principle of meaning
in a way
you have to have a handle of nature
and that also articulates how
Villages and how
practices around Agriculture and
and how people relate to each other
within these practices gets organized
specifically for uh one interesting
point that he makes that is
to appreciate
the constriction of that is like a
vision that notices not what within the
meaningful crops but we just left
outside the field of vision
and I bring that specifically to
understand how
for different principle can
or could be connected to a generalized
synchronization
over time
in relation to those symbols and those
practices in terms of Niche Construction
and
how those
how this Niche construction brings along
with the symbolic
and use of
language a predictive value
thank you friend wanna
bring up any thoughts on that or any
other
pieces or I'm happy to add a comment
Brynn
okay
um
a lot to say there there was a little
bit of a double play with what is
cropped on one hand what is cropped is
the industrial crop that is being
prepared
and
um and then the other side of that coin
is what is cropped out
and what what we crop in is the part
that we're paying attention to and we
can't pay attention to everything so
it's it's like two sides the same coin
what we pay attention to what we include
in attention in our cognitive awareness
leaves the shadow which is what we
exclude
and um that could be like the weeds or
the other ecosystem services so by
highlighting the meaning or one
dimension of meaning or one stance on
meaning
that only it's like a seesaw that
becomes Salient to the extent that
something else
must be de-prioritized
so that's how we accentuate these
distributions of meaning
and what do we get from active inference
and and free energy principle beyond for
example what's provided in seeing like a
state
I think there's a lot we could say on
that but one piece is we get a process
Theory
a real procedural approach to how
different systems come to
do sense making and cognition and action
so just describing the lay of the land
or the history of Forestry in Europe or
um any other state of affairs in the
world
merely describing it may not even help
us determine what's going to happen a
short time later let alone a long time
later or what might happen in a very
different ecology
whereas if we understand the processes
of sense making and decision making that
different kinds of cognitive agents do
certainly humans also though States as
cognitive entities which is what seeing
like a state or thinking like a state
entails
we get a process based View
on what otherwise might be merely
descriptive and along with that
process-based view we gain an increased
ability to make unique explanations
predictions accounts and so on
yeah we can we we can also understand we
can also
understand it
in a different perspective in terms of
realizing what
becomes sensitized and what becomes
desensitized
along the process so you can you can
possibly model that using this kind of
tools and understanding how that happens
over time right I don't know how
how much in terms of prediction
of things that were not foreseen in
these descriptions we can
we can achieve in fact
you can achieve some some level for sure
but
like that system should be decide how
how that delivers a very
all-encompassing prediction in this
country in these cases they don't
believe it can right I don't think
that's the purpose as well
but
we can
at least have
which is might not be as positive as
we won't but I think we can understand
how
okay we can gain some understanding in
this process of being more sensitive or
less sensitive to specific
primes and how this organization
organizational principles
uh how powerful they've become over time
yeah
I'll read some comments in the chat and
then Lorena or Brent feel free to just
give any thoughts just
upcycle Club wrote hello biomimicry can
enhance biosemiotics by showing us how
nature solves problems and creates
Beauty through signs and codes
and by encouraging us to apply these
principles to our own creations
yeah
the Jeff coding is an interesting idea
but to talk about codes I don't think
we CA that's my take right I don't
understand like you have we have encoded
uh any type of principles within our
uh cognitive ability but
uh biologically speaking
however you can understand these
encodings in terms of becoming more or
less sensitive over time to
environmental cues
as the example in terms of uh I use the
example of Forestry right
so in that specific case
this what becomes more
what you become more sensitive and the
more you organize your life or the
social life is organized around specific
principles
then you can make sense of these
relational stories
uh in instead of just leveraging unfold
um
difficult to explain notion of encoding
in terms of social cognition because it
will be hard to explain
how the brain will be encoding these
specific symbols but they can be cashed
out in the environment relationally in
terms of those organizational principles
and then you have this idea of
biomimicry like this
green iterations and how that comes
along in but
to explain what this mimic or this meme
will be then
a little bit not so so straightforward I
think
well certainly decompiling the source
code of nature
is somewhere between challenging and
misguided or impossible but that notion
of a code script for biology has
animated discussions of life going back
to for example Schrodinger's what is
life he basically says there's two
aspects of living systems there's their
organizational capacity their negotropic
capacity and then there's their code
script they're aperiodic crystalline
informational repository and then
another place that coding comes up a
little bit less in the source code space
is predictive coding
and that's in a way
highly compatible with active inference
and gives a deflationary account on how
the semiotics are encoded
rather than saying well this is what
this variable in the source code means
or this is what this code's for or
here's the code switch
predictive coding is like saying we're
not even going to touch the semantics of
what the sign is itself
we're just going to hypothesize that the
way that information about the sign is
transferred is through this maximum
information
signaling approach called predictive
coding because predictive coding arose
out of video compression algorithms and
only at the end of the 90s was found to
be increasingly relevant for neural
circuitry and so on
so it's another example of where like a
process based
approach
ends up deflating
or reframing
the
otherwise
semantically loaded question
it's like switching out the question of
like where we're going to be with how
we're going to get there
and instead of only focusing on the
meaning of the signs first off as if the
meaning of the science could be
discussed outside of their
implementation
and then even if we could figure out
what the signs were we would then just
turn around and want to know how they
were transmitted
and so predictive coding or predictive
processing
in a way short circuits that or inverse
it by first looking to explain how
information is transmitted that could
support
semiotics
and then in the context of biological
systems we naturally have biosemiotics
yeah
I would ask the question when you talk
about information being transmitted
right what that actually means and I
think that's a very very big topic and a
very large discussion in terms of
information information Theory when
specifically applying that into
um
biological systems I think there are
some interesting people working on
information that makes the case that
Shannon has a point and he's really
interested
not in the cement in the semantics or in
the meaning or anything else it's kind
of interested in the problem of
transmission and when you talk about
transmission
it was to ask what is being transmitted
exactly in the terms of of signals even
if you're capturing specific patterns
and you think that the partner is this
thing that will be transmitted in that
sense
but that would be a worse
um
I was asking questions
to understand like the
this notion of what is actually being
transmitted in that sense like is it
information this information theory is
focusing on this notion of the problem
of transmission and then all the the
concepts that come along to explain that
in terms of uncertainty or noise and
everything that
uh impact this transitional processes
and
if you're saying like we're transmitting
information in this sense that is
breaking this
semantic code apart yes it is because
like the problem is not focused on that
is that focusing on the specific
correlations that we have that we call
it they were mentioning as information
and how these correlations
are having issue from from the get-go
from what is being picked up in one side
being
correlated to what comes into the other
side right how that
how do you lose or gain more information
in that
but
the the
deeper question here is
uh how how can you say that you are
actually gaining or losing that
information because you are defining
this correlation that could be
transmitted or not
from the get-go if you don't have that
you don't have anything being actually
com actually communicated
so with that in mind you can
explain this Concepts in terms of
function and then there's a bunch of
theories that navigate this sense of
uh
signaling that is specifically only
functional and then predictive coding
tries to
trust to push that a little further
Maybe
but then you have to explain in
in a deep sense how this information is
being actually transmitted and processed
and I don't think that is really really
as obvious and as clear as we think it
is
specifically when you're talking about
this biological
way of nature navigating this process
this signaling
we have to talk about see because the
correlation if it's defined I've been
issue like from the beginning you then
only have this kind of transmission for
someone specific that can be able to
understand that in the other side right
well certainly whether we're talking
about
a chemical pheromone
that requires some type of receptor or
something more ephemeral like language
that requires more of a semantic
reference frame
there's no
receiving the message without the sender
it's like they're kind of the two sides
of the phone call
um I'll ask a question from the chat
love evolves
how about cultural encoding and
principles in contrast to organizational
so how do we think about
cultural meaning and is and is that
similar or different than organizational
yeah that's that's a good point right I
think if you take very seriously the
example from
the uh the forestry is a practice then
then I think it has to be organizational
in that sense the meaning navigate this
organizational
practice this organizational story that
that impacts
not only
communication between agents but also
how
how the environment will be interpreted
so and in this sense will be transmitted
and repeated over time because it has a
history and cannot ignore like the
history of this practices being pushed
further and replicated through
generations right
so
the way like the villages will be
organized in terms of that specific
practice for instance can be understood
in a meaningful and cultural way that
organizes life
in virtue of
some specific principles there
sensitizers uh agents towards
specific directions
and I think
how do I forget my point
uh for instance
you can talk about
uh
if you think about archaeological
findings and how
archaeological
descriptions of specific Villages and
how they navigate
this mapping out this this uh this
archaeological uh
sites they usually know exactly
if you have some kind of History already
from this this communities how this how
that City will be likely to be organized
first off like where is the water and if
the water is in certain directions
probably uh there will be certain kinds
of relationships with housing and
communal housings and where they're
gonna Place their dead in relation to
this kind of specific organizational
principle the water is here so
plantations will be not so far away from
that and
this city organizes like the village
organized a little bit in this sense and
that builds up
uh cultural practices
at least archaeologically can be
explained as such
I thought of something similar
um organization being the logistical or
the
operational
structural aspects so those would be the
roads that connect the forestry outposts
or the circulatory system that connects
the different organs of organization
and then the culture is a cause and a
consequence of organization
organization is the enabling conditions
for culture to arise okay so given this
road Network
what cultures arise how similar or
different are they convergently what are
their practices or their narratives that
are shared amongst these different
outposts
um or in in the bodily example okay
given the organization of the organs
literally the organizing process or
principle then what biosemiotics can
arise with glucose and insulin and
glucagon
and what culturally can arise
maybe even in terms of the generative
model of encultured Agents
as a function of organization and then
what are those encultured agents do
to the extent that they can modify
organization and so these kinds of
um
unrolling
cause and consequence relationships can
be hard to disentangle
because there's not like a clean single
starting point
that can be separated out
or because it unfolds historically
it's not exactly
a reaction in a test tube
so how does active inference give us an
entry points
into thinking about this
yeah I think oh that's something one
interesting thing about active imprints
that you you don't really need one uh
you don't really need an origin point
right you can start start modeling and
start understanding that at any any
given point and build up from from that
story and see how it unfolds
over time
I think that's the most beautiful idea
that you you define your parameters and
then you see from that parameters they
can be arbitrarily defined and you can
navigate
how things change within those
parameters in the generative model right
when you when you have your like
dynamical systems for instance you have
your state space they have some specific
range of
defining parameters that set
the limits of the possible states that
you're going to navigate and if you use
this notion
that these two densities brings about in
terms of position modeling you can use
these these kinds of tools to understand
how from that specific parameters
updates
what we narrate in active inference as
if belief updating
can change over time in these terms
that's a very nice point it reminds me
of Bruno latour's actor Network Theory
or ants which kind of Advocates a
similar approach to what you describe
which is like enter anywhere
open-mindedly
because in an iterated modeling or
iterated analysis setting the first
proposal or the first Trace detected
we know that's not the whole picture
there may not be a whole or only picture
so we need to answer and iterate and
then with active inference specifically
because of the compositionality that we
get within a layer Collective Behavior
and then also the kind of nesting
smaller things inside of bigger things
we can always build something
and then we can go oh wow it's like
there's a lot of top-down influence
maybe there's a a higher order factor or
slower factor or a contextual Factor we
should consider or oh we were
abstracting across these smaller things
inside but for a later day or if
relevant we can dive in
and so then
it allows a light holds or a grasp
on the proposed generative model
obviously it's map not territory but
even beyond that we always know that we
can expand laterally
and across scales
starting from anywhere
in an iterated
modeling process without our first or
even 11th model being proposed as like
the accounts of some complex cultural
phenomena which we're always gonna only
ever have our own perspectives on
yeah I think you don't really find that
in being so all in Corpus saying like
you have one model that will model them
all you can you you can navigate those
models in this More instrumental terms
it raises different questions when you
put things like that in terms of
genetology of models and uh models and
theories and Sciences but you they can
be also described as uh
tools for describe tools for adults for
for grasping in describing
phenomenon
in a more
non-committable way
how much that
how much that small girls in uh
philosophical or more ontological
problems it's still I think under like
debate
but
it is still
is still uh it is your children bring
insights
to think about
specific cultural
Collective uh phenomena which is not
it's it's complicated to
because I think what I'm getting at I'm
kind of like going back and forth but
when you talk about social sciences in
modeling usually you have like ways of
model modeling agents or ways of
modeling collectives and active
inferences trying to
to come up with a modeling in which you
can understand agency and collectives
within the same modeling uh schema
and I think the specific specifically
for these cases if you're interested in
understanding
types of cultural phenomena among
language users in
uh in a specific contexts you can at
least partially understand or have or
gain some insight in this agent
collected relationship that
that is a little bit more interesting
than
we have found so far in the social
sciences because you can have like or
specific understandings of memes but
then how the agent where is the agency
in that you you lose a little bit of
agency
well when you're trying to understand uh
only agents then you don't know how that
kind of scales up
because active inference tries and
offers this scale free
modeling tools that facilitates this
this
um
conversion into agents agents and
collectives
I would be interested in asking you
actually how
how do you navigate that when you talk
about social phenomena in ants or
termites or
because then yeah
you have very specific
coding demarcations I guess for for this
uh
social environments
yeah it's great
question it's also
whether it's a uh
open wounds or a a dirty closet that's
just shut there's actually a lot of
ambiguity and unresolved tension around
well
is the ant colony social are they social
insects that reifies the nest mate as
the individual and then what they're
doing is like when we hang out and talk
so reifying the nestomy as an individual
makes the colony social but if the
colony is individual
then what Nest mates are doing with each
other is not social any more than we
would describe the liver and the kidney
as having like a social single cellular
interaction but we know that would be
missing the point
and so there definitely is attention
with some of these evolutionary lineages
like ants being
monophyletically obligate usocial all
and only
ants are you social they all live in the
colonies there's no free living nestmate
whereas other
parts of the evolutionary tree
there are
life histories that do look a little bit
more like
social collaboration that can then
dissolve
and so knowing what level of lock-in
makes something
social
when are we socializing and what level
of lock-in goes beyond social and it
kind of like makes when the blanket is
so strong around the social
that
like for multicellularity
that it it's kind of losing the social
feature again
because if we just use social to mean
the connective tissue or the kind of
lubricant or the spaces between
everything
then it means nothing
so
a real tension is what space does the
Social account for
and is this going to be a
concept with a lot of creep
looking well it's a social relationship
between the roots of the tree and the
fungus
and it's a social relationship amongst
the molecules in the test tube is that
too broad of a social conception
are there downsides
or are there trade-offs associated with
the broader social concept
do we dilute what the social means and
then on the other side might we exclude
phenomena that could importantly be
considered social
well that's not social they're just
talking on a train it's like well that's
the other side if we were to have
carving out
encounters that we do want to include a
social and
is there a true social
does active inference help us sidestep
or at least negotiate this territory
because we could develop
a generative model or an ecosystem of
shared intelligence with one person and
two Internet of Things devices and a
bird
and a metronome
and just say we made what we made
and then leave it as a second order
interpretation
whether that is a social
setting
I mean I think you you are pointing out
like how other granularity of those
scales right if you have a model there
wouldn't you want to everything that you
already have it's probably not
interesting and not informative because
you cannot like Define those
limits of what you're trying to
understand
the other hand when you do that when you
define those limits if you're too narrow
or
you're gonna live out
you can idealize also in a way right and
leave out many other parts of of the
system that you're interested in
but if you don't do that
if you don't
if you don't make this this you should
make this decision when modeling you
think then how
how you can have any access to
to the phenomena right
and and to connect this to the forestry
so the forestry example
the
um desirata was Lumber now that may have
been a very
um narrowly scoped
desire but it's it's a relevant thing to
to want this resource and then
industrialization science as a process
um professionalization those allow the
description and and the handling and
ultimately the kind of top-down
um legibility and control thinking like
a forestry company
now with respect to the social sciences
by analogy to forestry science so now
we're entering an era of increased
legibility and control of social systems
and
human natural capital and attention as a
resource trust as a resource
in a way is being cropped
analogous to produce the contents of
lumber but now there are social contents
so as the social
goes from being just only simply the
water we swim in
not something that's even compared
counterfactually to alternative
cultural possibilities per se
but Falls
under the scope of the professional
management like Forestry
then that's when this discussion of well
what's the lumber and what is the weeds
that are being pruned
and what ecosystem services
when we pay attention to certain parts
of
Human Social culture
and when we seek to
make more of this kind of lumber
what else does that come along with
and what decisions
come into play
and that comes along when you see the
process
or Instagram I don't know Twitter after
what happened to Twitter but
um
foreign
you do have that very effectively
already happening already
you can see how that happens if
efficiently in the world in elections
for instance it can be very very easily
manipulated and we saw what happened
in elections for instance in Brazil or
in the US and
well all over
uh
you navigate a system of uh attention
organization there
selects in only
what he thinks that you're interested in
in the effects of that in terms of
decision making and in terms of trust in
terms of
diversity of discourse we have seen that
it can be devastating
the question would be like how can you
make these a little bit how can you use
active inference and these tools that we
have
to make this kind of Technology a little
bit more inclusive without being super
awesome disruptive
is it even like
a possibility I I really don't know I
think it's an ethical problem that we
have when we talk about social systems
and these principles of attention
exclusion leaving things out
a lot to say on that
um with modeling and interpolating
and models whether it's large language
model type or linear regression type
it
is able to
interpolate to put data points Within
um an enclosure
of what has already been described and
Bayesian statistics and other types of
prediction algorithms are not immune to
that either if we have some prior
distribution belief
um we believe it's possible for it to be
between 20 and 30 degrees outside
then when we get data inside of our
bounds
we can converge and that actually
tightens our beliefs not always a bad
thing of course
and then outside of the scope of the
possible those data are just seen as
noise and they may not even be
integrated so then that can lead to
reinforcing process
not necessarily an Adaptive One either
where information that's confirmatory is
used to ratchet and increase precision
and then information that is not
confirmatory
is discarded as not useful
it doesn't yeah in this case it's yeah
it doesn't even enter the uh
the landscape right
of attention of the user in
a
what I what I'm what I was thinking in
relation to this new this idea of
a forestry is because we have
now organizational principles that are
faster and
more populated with uh information and
attention grabbing
kinds of prompts
we transformed the same uh
we choose from the same principle into
um
a harder to grasp
process it's it's hard it becomes more
complex it becomes harder to describe
this is the process of understanding
that in terms of Forestry is kind of way
more grounded when you apply that social
into this kind of environment
that we're talking uh like internet or
this highly
uh volatile
uh
and virtual in principle in environment
it becomes much harder to assess what is
being pruned out or not you just don't
know it makes it more clear that
there is a process of pruning you need
to have no control of what is being
taken out
you have no idea what's being like left
away from your perspective of attention
so to this
topic of intended or unintended semantic
pruning I think um
this has helped me identify attention if
we want to talk about the semantics or
semiotics biosematics whatever we want
to call it of the letter E in
relationship to letter A
we're looking for an account
that might convey letterness but were
generalized above Enis or anus
so in some ways we've erased or
abstracted generalized away from the
particulars
of the sign
its meaning
by taking a semiotic perspective
and so it's like
we got into the game to have a semantic
account of biological phenomena or of
any phenomena for biological entity
yet
this process
in a sense
distances us from the particulars that
actually do granted that meaning
in the actuality like if we walk into a
Sacred Space and it's like oh well that
is just doing that over there and this
architecture is doing this
and because of the layout people must
use the room this way
that's
removed
from the actual
meaning
which is the cause and consequence with
the organization and culture that we
discussed
but that Prima fashion accounts
doesn't generalize
get any generalization that we make
so that we can talk about multiple
places or multiple letters on a common
accounting framework is going to remove
those particularities
so it's a very challenging Catch-22
whether we want to really
accounts for the N equals one
and maybe even live and act and play and
work in the N equals one
versus develop something that might be
satisfying and cut and dry
but it's always going to be on the
sidelines with respect to what it
actually means
what do you mean like is I don't
understand what you what you're getting
at like is it you mean like it's
generalized or not generalized it I
didn't get that like when we have a
general when we generalize
when we
ask what words mean
what what words mean Beyond any given
word we've lost touch with what any
given word means
um
but words are what they actually mean
in a situation
so it's just in this scientific approach
to meaning
semiotics and semantics
we have these two
tensions or pay attention to reconcile
between actually giving an account of
the meaningfulness
of the specific thing
versus taking a more scientific approach
which would be
Gathering a group of similar things
and finding their shared attributes
which out of necessity must abstract
must crop out
features
that
are are
empirically or
um anecdotally taken to not matter like
we abstract whether it was a Monday or
Tuesday that we did the experiments
we just combine all of our replicates
together when we do the scientific
analysis
you you mean
you mean if you generalize the practice
you lose
what you're being if you generalize it
too much you lose everything that's
meaningful joy in terms of like for you
formalizing
and then you have no yeah you you have
an empty semantics you have a semantics
there's no meaning that can only be
meaningful in terms of how you apply
that in terms of specific practices yeah
it's like I I have a framework for you
know the formal meaning of letters
within words within sentences within
paragraphs and then it's like well but
now what's your next n equals one word
that you're actually going to bring
it's not just about building some
abstract scaffold
yeah for a bigger and bigger Boulders of
meaning
at some point through our embodied
thought and action
in our experience it is going to come
down into the particulars
and it doesn't immediately seem clear
that simply generalizing further
brings us there
yeah yeah I particularly don't I I don't
really believe you can have that
kind of generalization I think we
attempt to build whatever
what I see that's the interesting aspect
of the formal semantics you try to build
this more General
uh understanding that just formalizes to
model but for that to be meaningful it
has to be embedded in a way of
practicing it like in a forestry
practice you have to be embedded in a
cultural environment in which that can
be actually
uh observed in terms of what happens
when a generative model is being updated
or not
is that what you mean because otherwise
I don't really understand how it becomes
too
yeah
it becomes too formal it becomes too
abstract in terms of some I would not
understand what that is
I'll think of a little more um Bran or
TJ do you want to add any
butter
questions
yeah sorry I I think like I don't have a
lot of context I've been like following
some of the discussion but not attended
a lot of these calls I'm like it's all
yeah yeah
um yeah I don't know uh I think
um
yeah I'm in general just sort of
interested in trying to understand the
relationship between
um yeah like
sorts of like constructionist
epistemologies and
um yeah like generator models and active
inference
um style stuff and
um how active inference style like yeah
what are the philosophical commitments
that active inference involves with
respect to knowledge and epistemology
and there's a sense in which like
rational Choice models often
assume a certain sort of like
um objectivity to beliefs and then
desires are where most of the degrees of
freedom lie or something
um whereas there's a lot of like issue
like there's a lot of things that come
up once you start talking about
reflectivities or concepts themselves
become self-fulfilling prophecies uh
what you believe about what your beliefs
about Society ends up shaping the
society itself so there's the sense in
which there's a codependence between the
object of knowledge and knowledge about
that object itself and I I think yeah
like I'm sort of interested in like how
the active entrance ways of thinking
about this
offers what perspectives on those
questions and stuff like that
um yeah
thank you great questions
yeah
so when you talk about the uh object of
knowledge and the knowledge itself and
active inference
uh
I think you you you can think of
in terms of this
well there's a few ways to think about
that I guess
uh the knowledge itself it has to come
epistemically from where your agent is
actually embedded and situated
specifically inactive influence it's
embodied he kind of needs to have a
model
the model is modeling your body he's
modeling a body that is in the world and
it's all the time uh situated is never
disconnected to its environment and it's
his how the history of that environment
right
yeah
uh
but if you think if you push that to the
object of that knowledge
I don't know how how different
um
that will
how different how can you different
differentiate that so sharply when you
talk about active inference
because
if you think of uh
in terms of a generative model did what
will be updated
comes is updated from a prior that is
always directed in this body in this
situated
uh Realm
so they sort of conflate as I see maybe
a maybe a mistaken but they sort of
coverage in how you're gonna update your
generative model which it will be at the
same time in at the same time
while you know and what you the object
of this knowledge
sorry if I can just like uh raise the
question to that yeah so I think like I
think that there is a sense in which
like with respect to something that an
epistemology would be called
self-knowledge there is there is a
question here that the the active
inference agent has
this model of that is like situated in
the body or like in in its like
um like structure and is also modeling
that structure itself and there is like
this issue of like where where
yeah like the belief is not
unidirectionally dependent on the object
sort of a thing but has this feedback
loop thing comes up there but there's
another way in which I think like uh
where this sort of thing comes where
even if the object is outside of the
body
of the knowledge I think that that could
still come up so for instance if I live
in if if an active infants agent lives
in a society
of other active influences where
currently all of them defect on
prisoners dilemma
but maybe like on further reflection
they would want to like again like I
don't know what further reflection would
mean in the act of inference sense but
I'm like just saying in the intuitive
sense like that what would it mean for
them to like go from one fixed point to
another fixed point where they're all
cooperating or or or something like that
and that that I think is not key to me
like how that shift can happen in active
inference where
it's not just purely using the empirical
information to keep
running the the middle of the of your
like
free energy equation but also
recognizing the contingencies
and then identifying those contingencies
to make something like
gifts from one state to another like if
if I model that the society is a cruel
space and if everyone models the society
is a group space then we will end up
creating a society that is a cruel space
but if only we could recognize that our
belief or our model that societies are
cool space is a contingent belief and we
could all somehow negotiate or
communicate and shift to a different
belief about what Society is and Society
is a kind place then we will end up
creating that kind of society or
something and
that sort of like a belief about the
thing that Society is
not entirely within the agent like it's
sort of it it it has a weird
intersubjective character so it's not
entirely outside of the agent either but
it's not entirely in like internal to
the agent either or something
you can think of that like you're
talking about active influence action
comes first right you have to you you
don't have the knowledge like
inside your head waiting for you to to
push that out of the action has to come
first so if you
if you take that as a principle an
organizing principle it depends on the
contingency of your actions the
possibilities might be limited by your
situated
um
condition for
they are limited it doesn't mean that
you don't have like
a range of options from that state space
in which you can go you can navigate so
you can navigate it for the good or for
the bad but it starts with the the
action perception Loop starts with the
action
I'll add a few other pieces on that
DJ very good point like
when we see the pragmatic component of
action as self-fulfilling
epistemic component of action having to
do with gaining knowledge and the
salience of information but the
pragmatic component is about bringing
our observations into alignment with our
preferences and then you identified two
related settings one of them is like
pure intra subjectivity like I expect
myself or I find myself or I habitually
think about X
well that's kind of a trivial
self-fulfillment because thinking about
something is its own fulfillments
and then when we're in this second
person or social space
we can agree on little performance or or
on a game
and games give evidence to that that
when people are able to perform
communication or message passing such
that new expectations or preferences are
set
whether more top-down like more seeing
like a state or more laterally more like
Collective Behavior then those regimes
can be embodied
and then you brought up a very important
point about the awareness of the
contingencies or where awarenesses of
adjacent possibles or of counterfactuals
so the body might be um we could model
its morphology as doing some computation
but that doesn't mean that the the
morphology has an awareness or can
explore a counterfactual
like bodies are not always exploring
every counterfactual
um because skin is in the game but again
mentally it's very cheap and easy to
consider counterfactuals and situational
awareness of social settings especially
if it can be not understood but
communicated
opens up a space where we're all playing
prisoner's dilemma now there's
parameterizations of prisoners
multi-agent prisoners dilemma where
tragically we just all defect all day
and never learn
there's also parameterizations where you
just start all cooperating and never
defect
and then the interesting settings are
where there might be like phase
transitions or where a perturbation
moves the system from one attractor into
another attractor
there's just a lot of richness and
that's the work of building generative
models and that iterated modeling
process
to to
unpack and refine
and
active inference isn't going to have a
stance on a prisoner's dilemma
we can use active inference to describe
the prisoners dilemma but active
inference isn't going to come down on on
literally even a little two by two Game
Theory Matrix
so we can then extrapolate that active
inference is not going to come down with
an opinion
on something significantly
more rich and real than a 2x2 Game
Theory Matrix
and so that work
is what
people enact
in applying active inference
right and I think like my question is
something like that insofar is like
humans try to constantly improve the
social games
how can we model that sort of a prior
over your actions or policies
that enables that sort of like
Progressive
um
um improvements or something
well
you can we are assuming that we're
trying to improve right we we don't know
that but we can model them as improving
but
like following Daniel's lead you we're
talking about this specific games and
contingencies they they this this
transitions from one state to another
specifically if you're talking about
this modeling of social
actors and talking about several actors
in your model involves several of them
will not be really linear right you
don't have like an easy
smooth transition of improvement you can
capture
over time as modeling
how they might tend to go towards a
direction and understand that as
Improvement but that takes
specific iterations that will not be
fully linear I guess
specifically if you want to understand
error and Improvement instead of trial
and error but fire and adding up into
this error like
error Improvement
but when you're modeling specifically
with dynamical systems for instance you
you're not going to see a full linear
story and I don't think you're gonna see
that
uh if you're modeling using active
inference in multiple agents agents
I'll add one piece there so how can we
go about modeling multi-scale social
goals
so
we could think about
different citizens in a region
and
they the modeler is going to choose what
knowledge to realize in the generative
model
like
what you put into the calculator it's
going to calculate upon now this happens
to be a elaborate
stochastic
method but if we only tell people yeah
there's just your personal income
optimize for that your preference is to
have that be higher well then the
simulation is going to unfold a certain
way if we say well there's your personal
financial income and then there's your
city and then there's your region
then that opens up
through through different
mechanisms you know maybe an individual
goes flat or neutral on the personal in
service of a larger win at a higher
level
well now what if the modeler says it's
not just about the financial income now
we're also going to have this secondary
Criterion
well now different agents could attend
differently to those two different
outcome variables
and maybe there's one simulation where
50 only care about this and fifty
percent care about that and it works
perfect or doesn't work
it's like a broad surveying you know or
Lego set or or
grammar or or active inference ontology
for
scoping very broadly and very
inclusively
but all the work is in the real
simulation developments
and sweeping
because very little could be said about
a game theory game if you didn't know
what the parameters were in The Matrix
you wouldn't know whether this
prisoner's dilemma
was going to be like an always
cooperator which agents with which
strategies would or wouldn't cooperate
if you don't know what the Matrix looks
like
so before
the values have kind of been filled in
it's just like actually describing the
adjacencies and the counterfactuals and
the contingencies of our scientific
model
but that's still prior to having the
model in hand
and the model you know so now we're
looking at that tree in the European
Forest
it's like well if I had this tool then I
could cut it down this way if I had this
tool I could cut it down this way or I
could wait it's like
that's
alternative actions about that tree
now in the social science setting
discussion of different scientific
methodologies are like counterfactuals
about that
social tree
yeah and specifically if you're
navigating this kind of game theoretical
models if that's what you're interested
in you can even Define in terms of
prisoner's dilemma for instance uh
specific values to see
what happens when everybody def uh
deflects and in how frequent modulate
those frequencies in terms of specific
uh in multiple iterations how
how are you gonna build up the wage or
the tendency of deflecting again if your
neighbor deflected once and deflected
twice or three times or
and see how that will accommodate
over time how many times this agent will
change its behavior until it stops
changing the behavior
but that you don't really
that's that that again you use you might
use a by Asian understanding a version
model for that but not necessarily
explained
uh
um
it does not necessarily explain the
action
fully I mean
social work you just you're modeling
only the interest of that specific actor
I I have a slightly meta question if I
can ask both of you uh I'm not sure how
these calls usually go uh I'm curious
what are your interests in active
inference what do you think like what
brings you to active inference and like
what do you think
what do you think active inference adds
to our theoretical understanding and in
what ways or something
the right Nick go for it
well
I think I was trying to touch upon that
before and how we can
if you're navigating for instance
behavior in terms of Game Theory this
kind of modeling if you're talking about
like trust games for instance you're
gonna understand how this
to addict interactions evolve over time
specifically over interactions
but you don't have an account
of change because I have very limited
options of actions
and
you don't have an account also on scales
and I think active influence tries to
Edge a little bit and account of how you
can scale that and how uh
uh
how can add more parameters into the
game and see how they evolve with a more
clear
uh
understandings of a richer understanding
that for instance when you talk about
specific interactions in Game Theory
so when that's one
one aspect that active influence kind of
contributes another point is because we
have this
parameterization that is specifically in
terms of belief updating and also in
terms of Dynamics
we are always talking about
agents that will be situated and
embodied and have a very specific uh
synchronization with the environment all
the time because when you talk about
active inference the action comes always
first so you have a less you try to have
a less reductive model
especially anywhere you want to model uh
cultural agents and Collective action I
think that's kind of desirable that's
what you're looking for
is it also your area of Interest
sorry is it also your area of Interest
mine or is that Lorena's area of
Interest
what do you mean
oh sorry like my question was also like
what brings you to
active and friends and I think you
answered a lot of ways in which active
inference adds theoretical value but I
wasn't sure like if that was also your
subjective interest or motivation as
well subjective interest yeah and I'm
curious to see how that pans out right I
I'm interested in how that helps us to
to think of this type of uh
phenomena
and I'm very interested in how this
relationship for agents to collectives
and Back Again work like
um
I think it might give us some
well you give us some very insightful
way of modeling these relationships
and navigating it as you want because
this this uh feature of being scale free
is kind of helpful in
to looking things you can you can Define
your
uh Markov blanket in terms of are you
interested right and see what happens
I don't know yeah I'll just give a few
thoughts even though also surely some of
these thoughts are are scattered
um you're asked DJ what is active
inference add to our theoretical
accounts of the social
it does many things in in my view and
that's what makes it so valuable
epistemically and pragmatically it gives
us the expressivity
within a scale to describe Collective
behavior and across scales to describe
nested systems so that brings continuity
to discussions of the social with
broader discussions of the biological
ecological computational physical and so
on so that's a multi-scale
transdisciplinary element
active inference provides us with
legible first principles
which can either be taken instrumentally
as just heuristics
and also in certain situations can be
viewed empirically
as
justifiable first principles and then
from those legible first principles
which are not English specific
they're already in a space
that has a lot more
possibility and promise
than for example a mere enumeration of
important adjectives or nouns
we can develop lists of important
adjectives and nouns
when we have a broader cognitive
modeling framework
and so this methodological turn
then supports just a tremendous
diversity of thought and work
instead of asking us to kind of go
through the eye of the needle and you
know get on board with this one
ranking of features and then try to
apply it more broadly that's like an
overfit before the cart situation with
active we can expand the methodological
discussion
connected to theoretical physics and
Mathematics in ways that really haven't
been seen before
and then that opens up more than it
closes down
it brings up more questions than it
resolves in and of itself but it opens
the questions that can be resolved
like what generative model can I make
that will keep the temperature in this
building livable
but active inference isn't going to have
a stance on what you should do for that
building
so we need to in a way take a step
in the methodological Direction
which I see as moving towards active
inference to enable
a million steps in different directions
hmm
I have a bunch of questions here uh
I think one is probably just a reference
question uh the three topics that I'll
say if you guys have any papers or
articles on those things I would love to
like get a reference one is
in what ways can we model a collection
or an aggregation of active influences
as a
like super agent or like super like
active infant super agent or something
and like how how does this like
decomposition and aggregation
uh like flexibility work in different
contexts like if there's like
work that tries to either make
informal commentary or formal modeling
either ways I would love to see that
secondly you just click on the first
just on the first
check out the previous section of this
course on Collective Behavior where I
reviewed many such works great thanks
okay is it on the same notion
is it linked from the same notion thing
all in the same places and in the same
playlist with this core same syllabus
yes good okay
um the second is is that an active
entrance account of
same markets or economic interaction
wherein like your your prices act as
some sorts of like information signals
and like like can can use active
inference to then talk about aggregation
in
of Market entities or something I'm
guessing this would also be covered in
the same list indeed people have
explored cognitive economics and people
are working on it but that doesn't mean
it's a done deal theoretically or
especially in practice so keep going I
think it's quite experimental still but
there are a bunch of people working on
that I guess
I I don't remember any specific paper
right now but I can I can look it up and
uh
forward to you but yeah yeah it would be
great uh I can drop my email address
here yeah sure
uh the third is probably more trickier
than both of these which is is there an
active inference account of natural
language
um
yes thankfully colleagues like Elliot
Murphy and others
have explored specifically the
linguistic aspects of
natural speech I think Lorena's
lecture and area focus
generalizes a bit beyond specific
natural language because we're talking
about semiotics and semantics in a more
Intermodal sense however yes there's
been limited work from a computational
Linguistics and neurobiology perspective
on speech
okay so then
uh
okay so you said something like false
principles stuff when you're making a
commentary on what act of Interest
brings
I have still I have I'm still often like
struggling what is active inference
offering and I like try to encounter
different things I think I enjoy a lot
of philosophical questions that oh the
the conversation opens up but like I'm
still like really ambivalent about the
theory
um and when I read like this new book uh
which Tristan has not written uh but
like is and go author I don't remember
was the name of the book
um
um I don't yeah I don't exactly remember
there's a book right which is like
supposedly like supposed to be the Canon
and like Tristan as a co-author but in
the preface he says
so that's the 2022 par friston pezula
textbook
yeah yeah
I wouldn't quite say it's the Canon
since it's a short book but certainly it
is a landmark moment for the fields
right and when I read that
the one thing that bothered me was
it brings up the helmets uh free energy
thing
but it sort of argues it by Fiat like
okay this is a simple principle it can
Model A lot of things but that doesn't
tell me why I should why I should trust
it like what what is the reason to act
why that why does this principle lead to
cognition like what like sure your
positive a very simple principle and
then said hey look this simple principle
can explain so many things but well it
can it also explains things that don't
look like cognition and like like I'm
not sure like there's an I got an
account of why that principle is like
uh works or something
the right nickel for it I'll think of
some other ways to say it yeah you you
can think of like modeling by
construction and modeling by first
principles and if modeling by first
principles you have
you have some limitations in which you
cannot fully explain some things
but
the virtue of the model and how the
first principle organizes everything
that comes along with the model usually
might be sufficient or might be a useful
a useful tool to help you explain that
phenomena that based on the first
principle that you were bringing along
and that's one way of one part of
answering this question is I think it
might be a big question for the
for the field
yeah here's some short little threads on
that
yeah we can describe
maladaptive cognitive systems or
adoptive cognitive systems whether
something's adaptive or not is always in
relationship to its Niche like the
foraging algorithm that works in the
desert doesn't necessarily work in the
rainforest so these systems are not like
intrinsically adaptive or not we want to
have natural language that allows
sentences that are valid and invalid and
have different kinds of semantics so
again this is just an expressivity
framework
that enables people to build cognitive
models of high reliability or important
settings or you could make something
that looks just like a beautiful circuit
board and not even worry about what the
outcome is so so yeah for sure you can
describe all kinds of systems that would
be like
um having a uh less than functional
methodological system if we said well
we're doing a linear regression
framework but we only want positive
regressions it's like well not the
methodological level we wanted to be
able to do any slope so here in the
cognitive modeling setting we want more
expressivity so that we can actually
construct the ones that we're interested
in and then how does this
really do cognition
how is it that a first principles like
surprise minimization or the bounding of
surprise through free energy how can
that really cover
so many cognitive phenomena
that's the question and the play but how
is it that Newton's Laws of Motion can
describe so many objects
being dropped off a tower
how is it that Bayesian mechanics can
describe so many different priors being
updated
and so by understanding cognitive paths
as Paths of least action which is the
free energy principle
a wide variety of models
become
of us of a similar account
now become available yeah
whether that's useful to a given person
in a given setting like if you make an
active inference model of your business
it doesn't mean you're going to succeed
if you make a self-driving car with
active inference it doesn't mean it's
gonna work
this isn't a guarantee of success
but it's a method that can be utilized
and we know that the method reaches
different kinds of modeling outcomes
and supports
subsequent perspectives and models from
where it reaches
but we can't a priori limit where the
method reaches to like only the
successful ones or only biological
systems
then we wouldn't even have the
expressivity to talk about cognitive
ecosystems with synthetic intelligences
um and when you're talking about
cognition also we can use this kind of
first principles
two model aspects of cognition but you
might not necessarily think that
cognition is all encompassing like that
everywhere all the same but you can use
that to model specific things that
you're interested in in cognitive
behavior like adaptivity does it give me
any insight to understand what is
adaptive adaptive behavior for instance
in which kind of insights do I get are
they interesting are they useful so
that's what they're availability that
this kind of model brings along so you
can you don't have to believe in in the
whole story but it gives you a lot of
Leverage to ask ask questions and what
kind of questions you'll be asking
okay so let's say that like like Acro
inference and free energy allows me to
talk about systems
uh but
does it give also give me vocabulary
to then classify those systems
in terms of let's say adaptivity would
be one
property but like there could be other
properties in terms of like
how much
how rich the world model is or stuff
like that or yeah
um if you have a portfolio of generative
models
you could summarize them according to
the TJ statistic you could summarize
them according to the number of nodes
you could put them into a common
environment or different environments
and summarize their activity in any
number of ways
but we can't
talk about a ranking or a summarization
of a portfolio of generative models
that's not in hand
this is a framework that lets us build
those diverse generative models
and then in a very open-ended way do
model comparison model selection model
adequacy
all the kinds of complex systems
engineering
methods
that we want
and also I would
ask you where do you see appear
or a comparison first principle
you know active inference has legible
first principles which are reflected in
the active inference ontology and
expressions using it which can be
represented in natural language so
that's the talking about it but it's not
only represented in natural language
other Frameworks have other first
principles that may or may not be
legible
and
people may choose difference yeah to go
down for whichever number of reasons
you can compare them and see which one
gives you the best inside that you're
looking for
well so yeah I think like
something that I could compare to active
inference is like say the Bayesian
utility maximization thing
and which has a different ontology I'm
not a fan of that either like that also
I'll just Bayesian utility maximization
is a special case of free energy where
there's no epistemic value
all you have is pragmatic value and so a
special diminished
not necessarily you have value of
information and you have explore exploit
trade-offs in Bayesian utility
maximization as well like you like like
if you load into your utility function
if you can beg the question and load
epistem into pragma you're right then
all you need is pragma but in expected
free energy we have epistemic and
pragmatic value which is what enables us
this expressivity but I think we're
aligned on that
right I I think like I'm somewhat like
also slightly confused because in the
Bayesian utility like between the
languages comparing the languages as
such like in the Bayesian utility
maximization
the exploration parts that are
prioritized based on
your X and the
estimation on the value of information
uh whereas
I'm not sure that holds true for the
active inference model as well that the
episode The epistemic exploration is
prioritized or valued in terms of some
of the same uh pragmatic thing as well
you'll yeah you'll have a a a lot to
explore and learn you can make a model
that is 80 20 or 2080 or 100 zero
between epistemic and pragmatic there's
nothing we can say across generative
models about whether active inference
prioritizes episteme or not because you
can make a model that's a hundred
percent or zero
sorry I I meant more like does active
inference allow us to talk about systems
or the Bayesian utility maximization
doesn't allow us to talk about but yeah
I'm talking particularly about
expressive power of the language yeah um
like is it like are there things that
the Bayesian utility maximization can
talk about that active infants cannot
other things that active influences
two short answers one short answer
utility maximization must cram epistemic
value into pragmatic value
we gain more expressivity when we can
articulate out pragmatic value which is
the alignment of preferences with
observations from epistemic value which
is Information Gain so that's a huge
articulation and the second thing is
when you're in a anything maximization
framework when you're in a utility
function now again begging the question
how you constructed this function that
you're trying to maximize when you're in
a maximization framework we have a
well-known set of approaches for finding
local and Global Maxima using
optimization or maximization Frameworks
what octave inference uniquely provides
is it describes the path that that
cognitive thing takes
as a path of least action that minimizes
surprise
so instead of climbing to the top of the
hill up are we on a Foothill or are we
on the biggest hill
we're like a ball rolling to the bottom
of the hill finding the least surprising
path now that least surprising path can
still include novelty and Information
Gain
but it turns out to be a lot more
tractable and connected with statistical
physics and quantum mechanics when we
talk about the path of least action ball
rolling down the hill rather than this
sort of question bag on top of a
mountain climbing adventure Bayesian
utility approach
but it's up to each person to feel how
they want to feel
yeah
it's a little a little bit what's in the
book as well when you take the low and
the high road for free energy principle
right
because how much you want to have your
utility maximization function being
disconnected to the department to the to
the action
because when you Model Behavior it will
be hard to do that independently like
you have a lot of you have way more
assumptions you are committing to much
to a greater level of assumptions for
your utility function we if you don't do
that
because it's the pragma with with the
action first that pragmatizes you you
you have reasons to describe reasons to
believe why that information gain works
the way that it does
you can leverage some explanations on
that without it you you have you have
you you have a model that has more
assumptions and I think if you have a
model with less assumptions it's always
healthier let's say so
yeah so I think like that that that does
talk about the compare compare the
analysis of the expressivity but I I
would also say as a matter point that
like I'm not happy with either of those
languages but I'm like I am suspect that
both of those languages claim certain
ontological
assumptions and I'm like always
suspicious but like where are these
ontological assumptions coming from
a few other points we tap into
an absolutely
meaningful Nexus of statistical methods
and message passing schemes
with active inference if you can State
something in the active inference
ontology and construct a generative
model then
message passing algorithms can be
deployed that contractibly compute that
model so that's absolutely non-trivial
otherwise it's possible just to get
wrapped up in some analytical formalism
but then once you want to do that on a
4K video
now you're on Square zero with the
computer engineering this is not that
way
and then I will respond to your meta
point with a metapoint which is
when we've enumerated the alternatives
the one that we like best personally I
feel happy with I'm also open to New
Alternatives arising but being
unhappy when all things considered is in
play
why
what bothers you specifically on the
ontology of
the active influence
yeah like I I think like I'm still
looking for
I I don't know what exactly I'm looking
for but I feel dissatisfied with the
account given for why hell models free
energy
least action thing like
is the central thing here or something
like why does it work like why does this
principle
there's a lot of funny answers I could
give there yeah that that Delta that
discrepancy
that's curiosity and that's the space of
the open and that's learning and that's
your unique contribution to make
and that's everything so that's not just
a thorn in your shoe that's like
our experience of action amidst
uncertainty
which is the water we're in
and so whether we take a higher order
narrative perspective on that
discrepancy being dissatisfying or that
discrepancy being satisfying I think
it's pretty nice I just need to minimize
my surprise there
yeah and you can choose to minimize your
surprise through your attention
you can choose to minimize surprise at a
higher narrative order like I'm
satisfied and complacent that I don't
understand number Theory but I use
numbers to count objects around me
so that discrepancy and understanding
knowing that there's a thousand years of
research that could be done on numbers
it doesn't unsettle me but for someone
else that might be unsettling and that
might lead them to ruminate it also
might lead them to do a PhD in number
Theory so just different paths for
difference individuals and contexts
but there's always so many Technical and
meta levels with active huh
okay so I don't want to like keep you
guys over time uh but I would ask one
last reference based thing which is
other active and Friends accounts of
seeing like a state phenomena
uh in any literature I think I heard you
mentioned it once so I was like yeah
like this
yeah check out live stream 33 series but
also this course that were literally
actually enacting in
with avell
is where these
accounts come to roost and where we're
creating a space to develop it and it's
not a cathedral for us just to spectate
at today but if you want to make an
active inference generative model
of whatever social setting when you have
the model in hand
a lot of your questions will be
sidestepped
okay where is the 33 thing that you
mentioned if you go to the page with all
of our Instagram live streams and look
in the live stream series like the paper
discussions
in the 33 series there's a DOT zero
video with background and context and
then we have a DOT one and a DOT two
conversation with authors but avell
who's also the course coordinator for
this course and Kairos research like
evils and and colleagues work has
heavily built on the seeing like a state
thinking like a stay optimal grasp all
these different topics
yeah I'm yeah I'm on your YouTube
channel I'm slightly finding it hard to
find the thing
um if you look up live stream zero three
three point zero or if you go to in the
video description of any video where it
says all live streams here go there and
search for but you'll you'll find it and
you can always email us we're going to
get in contact but yeah
and I think our valves paper are like
thinking like a state also can help you
a lot to understand how
how uh active inference modeling is
useful for the social sciences in
comparison to other types of modeling he
makes a comprehensive description
interesting
great thanks uh yeah and this is this is
our first iteration on this course we
are going to continue
bringing new information to the table
and supporting individuals who want to
build generative models you know around
this area
whether it's part of the internship
program or part of a course credit or
different kinds of programs that we'll
be able to develop
but
this is the real thing and we're able to
work with people who want to think and
do
make sense
indeed any closing thoughts on TJ then I
will go and then Lorena with last word
um no this was great thanks thanks to
the conversation
thank you all thank you for Brandon TJ
for joining Lorena for the
lecture this was a fun discussion we
never really
know where how it's gonna go but
I'm glad that we could cover so many of
these
topics and
probably raise more questions and
footholds
van door slams so thank you again Lorena
yeah thank you for inviting me and I
think active influence
like holds a lot of space for
experimenting as well as some things you
try to see if they make sense and
they're gonna hold up and open new
questions and that might be an
interesting aspect of
uh of the framework itself
thank you everybody thank you everybody
for the great live chat comments there's
a lot there I couldn't read it all so
until next time
but
foreign